so today nevada's democratic attorney
general advertisement aaron ford weighed
in on how the election has been handled
so far
and also addressed concerns from voters
kate houston is on this story she joins
us now in our 8 news down newsroom with
what he had to say yes attorney general
ford spoke
directly to voters during a facebook
live interview with battleborn
progress and he tried to reassure
nevadans that all of their votes
will be counted now throughout the
interview ford touched on
several different topics one issue
brought up was the time it's taking to
deliver
election results ford reminded voters
that many nevadans took advantage of the
vote by mail process
there are also many safeguards in place
to prevent fraud from happening
which means it could take longer to
receive results overall ford says all
evidence shows that nevada has conducted
a safe fair
and secure election i will leave the
hysteria and the hypa and the hyperbole
to those who are attempting to undermine
this process because you know that's not
what i'm here to do what i'm going to do
is to defend the process one that is
legal lawful
safe and secure and that's going to
guarantee every lawful vote that has
been cast is going to be counted
attorney general aaron ford went on to
say that politicians will not decide who
wins this election
it's the american voters who will decide
he wants the will of the people in
nevada to speak for itself
now this conversation also touched on
some topics such as
the vote counting process and how
signatures are validated
reporting from the newsroom tonight kate
houston back to you